let's go to our top photos right now
we'll come back with Ellen bout her
hearing we are starting in Greece in
fact Tom in Athens and some time with
square thousands of demonstrators
rallied into the night after the country
and post capital controls and closed its
banks we heard Erik schatzker saying
12,000 of them but it was partially a
rally that was sort of a organized not a
protest Eric was real specific this is a
real as well well so we know that the
referendum on Sunday is going to be
whether the Greeks should accept an
economic reform package foot for fight
the creditors bailout deal expiring what
else we have so next photo is an uber
passengers again in the China code
across he's freaking out of traveling
continents in style the right healing
company just announced a new speed boat
service and Istanbul is called uber both
funnily enough ferry passengers across
the Bosphorus River it does and it
divides the Asian and European sides of
the city of course the Bosphorus
depending on the route prices range from
just about eighteen dollars to 161
dollars that's something I want to try
mm-hmm not on the helical you burn your
comforter as well all right number one
for our photos today this Portuguese
man-of-war jellyfish washed up along the
Jersey Shore this weekend the tentacles
grow from 10 to 30 feet long marine
biologists warn that they're potentially
deadly stinking calls abdominal or chest
pain changes in pulse fainting headache
muscle pain spasms difficulty swallowing
you want we want some more symptoms man
anyways in New Jersey this isn't New
Jersey this is on the shores of
Stephanie ruhle Stephanie's gonna let
her children out there with a jellyfish
like I think we need to warn her it
looks like a worn brillo pad frankly
it's okay when you need her there she
would be able to do something about this
man a warm it is a scandal chris
Christie get on that right now jellyfish
on the new jersey sure